this is the very first caste that I have
ever worn it was the day I was born
there's my little knee and this is all
the way to my thigh that's how tiny my
leg is and they put this on me to
straighten my leg
my name is Marta Michelle I'm a
singer-songwriter and I have
arthrogryposis it's a muscle and joint
disorder ayuh stiffness in the joints
and weakness in the muscles or a lack of
muscles I can't walk I am in a
wheelchair for the rest of my life and I
can't lift my arms above my head but
other than that I am relatively capable
of doing most things I was 12 years old
and I entered into a talent contest and
I decided to sing I won the talent
competition and I decided this is what I
want to do for a living and people
always ask me why and it's because of
the fact that when I was on stage I
forgot that I was incapable of walking
or that I couldn't
high-five someone because my arms don't
go over my head I was just on stage
singing a song and people were enjoying
it and singing along with me and I was
like this is what I want to do for the
rest of my life since sixth grade
I pursued singing I was in choir I would
enter into competitions outside of
school and then when I hit sixteen that
was when I started auditioning for TV
shows like x-factor and American Idol
and The Voice the challenges I've come
across our people not believing in me
people who asked me questions like what
is the wheelchair going to do for you in
this industry and my answer is always
the same the wheelchair will get me on
and offstage your question should be
what is your voice going to do there was
this one time that I auditioned for a
singing competition on the television
and I remember going in and I sang my
song and they said to me we like you we
like your voice but we don't like the
wheelchair because it's an eyesore so
I'm like sitting there I'm not gonna be
on your show because not not cuz I'm not
talented but because my wheelchair is an
eyesore that was probably my least
favorite experience I've had because I
definitely don't believe that your
talent should be related to what's
attached to you and my wheelchair is
definitely attached to me but it's not
what defines me
[Music]
I'm on my way to a performance that I'm
really excited / nervous about I'm
performing an original that I wrote by
myself and I really love the meaning of
it and I hope that people love the
meaning of it and I just love being on
stage and singing and performing and
connecting with an audience and feeling
like I can do anything in the world I'm
so excited and I hope it goes well the
song is all about being super confident
and not giving up on your hopes and your
dreams and being strong and I just
really hope that people in the audience
connect to the song the way that I
connected when I wrote it and I'm just
feel like this is gonna be a pretty cool
song I'm gonna perform right over there
I'm so excited I want to show that the
disabled community has bunches of talent
just because you're different doesn't
mean you can't aspire to be a doctor or
a veterinarian or a lawyer or a dancer
I'm not saying I can do anything cuz I
really don't believe that I can't ever
walk but the things that I can do and
the things I believe in myself are doing
they're definitely gonna happen you have
to believe in yourself
you do in your goal
little
keep in monsters
[Music]
do it
take away your face
yes Jane
[Music]
there's paths
[Music]
and don't give up against I do so and do
you can't do
can do
stay tuned
people with disabilities we have to
believe in ourselves way more than
anybody else because a lot of people
will look at us and they will say she's
not gonna 60 I thought a lot of people
will watch this and think she's not
gonna go anywhere because what I don't
care what they think I'm gonna go places
because I'm the one that writes my own
story
[Music]